i had so much fun with all of you today
what a great way to go into the weekend
and you our virtual family and friends
vffs
thank you so much you guys
listen i always talk to everybody after
the show
and so i just wanted to share a little
sentiment that we like to
tell everyone which is that i want you
to know how much it means to me that
you're here
okay we are so grateful for the fact
that you
choose to spend time with us i know that
you could be watching or doing a million
other things
and the fact that you choose to spend it
here with us
and really set the stage for us all
coming together and building this
community
from all over the country and other
countries too sometimes
you have no idea how important this is
and how much you elevate the show
with your energy and presence both in
that energy
and the way this all looks this wall
reminds me of a photo album
every time and it makes me emotional so
thank you
because you make this show better and
if you want to be one of our vff's and
come
join us then visit the drew
drewberrymore show.com to reserve
tickets and you can also connect with us
on twitter at drewberrymoretv and on
facebook and instagram at the
drewberrymoore show
all right you guys thank you so much
[Music]